Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two. David P. I want to be clear,
this is satire. This is not really
anti-vax content, but here is a caller
telling me about some really weird vaccine
side effects that he got. This is funny.
Speaker 3: Hi, days, it's just watching
your episode about the unhinged, anti-vax
woman, you know, at the school board, you're
anti-Semitic rant. And I just want to go on record
as saying I've had both the vaccine shots, both of
Pfizer early this summer, and I'm feeling great,
except maybe for picking up telepathic messages
in the dark gods consumed by the ghost of H.P.
Lovecraft. But that's a different matter. I just
put some tinfoil in my hat and I'm going to go.
Exactly. So just let everybody know there's no
problem with the vaccines we're good at. There's
currently the ghost of H.P. Lovecraft, right?
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. Yeah,
I'm actually I'm going to be getting my third
dose scheduled for later this week. I will
report to you what symptoms I have. You know,
it did happen that when I got my second dose,
I did kind of trip on a curb and stub my toe
on the way out. And so that I don't know if
I'm supposed to report that in the Veirs system,
but it did take a couple of days to heal and it's
sort of like chipped a little bit of my toenail.
OK, we've got a great bonus show for you today.
We're going to talk about the right wing hysteria
over Big Bird and getting vaccinated. It's crazy.
We will also talk about the Supreme Court, which
will hear arguments on the FBI's surveillance
of mosques. This is still a story, and
we will talk about Philadelphia's ban
on low level traffic stops. What does that mean?
What qualifies as low level? All of those stories
and much more on today's bonus show. Sign up
and get instant access at Join. Catherine Ofcom.